herzlich willkommen zu unter den linden
seiten wurde in deutschland so heftig
diskutiert und gestritten wie in letzter
zeit über die flüchtlingskrise und ob
wir das schaffen über die stellung des
islam in unserer gesellschaft und über
die rolle europas eine neue partei die
afg ist entstanden und erstarkt union
und spd haben an zustimmung verloren
ist dies alles normal der ausdruck einer
lebendigen debatte einer
funktionierenden demokratie oder droht
uns ein verlust der mitte unser thema
heute die gespaltene nation mit einem
fragezeichen streit um flüchtlinge islam
und europa und das sind unsere gäste
thilo sarrazin umstrittene autor
zahlreicher sachbücher soeben erschienen
sein neues buch wunschdenken
herzlich willkommen und ich begrüße
jakob augstein herausgeber der
wochenzeitung freitag autor einer
regelmäßigen kolumne beim spiegel und
streitbarer part des duos aus stein und
blume bei phoenix herzlich willkommen
zwei gäste die in vielerlei hinsicht
unterschiedliche pole unserer
gesellschaft repräsentieren und ich bin
gespannt ob ihr trotzdem an der einen
oder anderen stelle einen gemeinsamen
nenner finden
herr sarrazin wie würden sie dann den
zustand unserer gesellschaft im moment
beschreiben sie ist im kern gesund
aber es gibt es gibt elemente die wenn
das so weitergeht
doch vieles auf die dauer gefährden eine
der gesellschaft mit 80 millionen und
einer der starken wirtschaft ist wie ein
großer tanker wäre da geht es im
augenblick mal kapitän ist und was
falsch gemacht das ist nicht so wichtig
wenn man aber in bestimmten fragen
dauerhaft irgendwo in die der falsche
richtung fährt dann kann es mit der zeit
sehr gefährlich werden und das ist bei
uns der fall
herbstein sind wir mitten einer
lebendigen debatte über flüchtlinge und
islam oder läuft etwas grundsätzlich
schief
wir haben eine lebendige debatte die
ganz schön schief läuft würde ich sagen
weil wir bestimmte standards der debatte
über bord geworfen haben
anstand zählt inzwischen gar nicht mehr
so viel vernunft zählt auch praktisch
nichts mehr faktentreue spielt auch
keine rolle sondern es platt hat jeder
alles wild vor sich hin als ein bisschen
so als hätte man das internet von der
leine gelassen so der öffentliche
diskurs inzwischen sowieso eine debatte
bei twitter und facebook so ohne risiko
kann jeder jeden unseren verbreiten
der diskurs da sind sie mittendrin mit
ihrem neuen buch werden wir schauen uns
dann mal eine kurze passage abend
wunschdenken wie gesagt da habe ich
folgende passage rausgesucht nicht ganz
kurz aber war jetzt wichtig dass wir das
im zusammenhang hören
ich hab das mal vorlesen der wunsch eine
willkommenskultur zu zelebrieren und
sich selbst mit einem heiligenschein zu
versehen führte zur größten krise
deutschland seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
für den vergänglichen glanz nahm die
bundeskanzlerin eine ungestörte kultur
fremd
einwanderung in kauf die langfristig den
wohlstand deutschlands gefährden und
einem kulturbruch verursachen kann der
die identität der nation zerstören kann
grösste krise deutschland seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg kulturbruch warum so
dramatische worte geht es nicht eine
nummer kleiner
und zwar muss man immer fragen ob eine
sache einmalig ist oder ob sie bleibt
die die also gegenwärtige nach der
flüchtlingspolitik ist so angelegt dass
sie bleibt sonst hätte sie von anfang an
keinen sinn gemacht wenn man wenn man
sondern lässt die grenzen zu machen will
hätte man sie auch schon vor einem jahr
zu machen wollen das heißt diejenigen
die das betrieben haben nehmen neben
dauerhafte einwanderung in hohen zahlen
aus anderen aus anderen nach dem fremden
kulturen in kauf und der verleugnen vor
sich und vor anderen was das für folgen
hat das
das würde nur dann funktionieren wenn
der mensch praktisch eine blanke der
schiefertafel wäre und beliebig formbar
wäre das ist ja aber nicht die menschen
die der zu uns kommen kommen aus einem
ganz anderen umfeld mit einem ganz
anderen kulturellen hintergrund und wie
sich auch an unseren bisherigen
einwanderungs erfahrung zeigt haben wer
also große gruppen aus nach afrika
der name mittel ost wirke sich auch
mindestens zu teilen nach der 40 bis 60
jahren in ganz europa da sehr schlecht
integrieren und darauf setzen wir noch
eines drauf und machen mehr vom selben
und das wird auf die dauer gefährlich
zumal weil wir das sehr geburten arm
sind und diese gruppen durchschnittlich
er heiraten mehr kinder haben letztlich
uns auch deshalb wenn das so weiter geht
in wenigen jahrzehnten zu einer nach
dazu eine minderheit im eigenen lande
machen werden auch wenn er viele nicht
gerne hören wie zum beispiel heran
ich würde ihn wahnsinnig gerne zu weil
es ist ein bisschen so wie früher so
wenn man sich so in winter eingemummelt
hat und somit decke und dann kommt einer
und erzählt erzählt ein anderer großer
geschichten wenn man ihnen zuhört dann
muss man sagen am besten werden die
ersten früheren vor menschen die aus
afrika ausgewandert denn da kommen wir
alle her weil anpassung an neue
lebensräume neue kulturen völlig
ausgeschlossen
jeder bleibt am besten da wo man ist
also ich glaube das was sie da reden ist
das ist das was ich vorhin meinte
entschuldigen sarrazin bei einem respekt
es ist einfach echt unsinn weil die
europäische geschichte besteht aus
wanderungen die amerika ist ein
einwanderungsland kanada ist ein
einwanderungsland australien ist ein
anwalt ausland übrigens auch die
bundesrepublik deutschland ist schon
seit ganz langer zeit ein
einwanderungsland
wir haben damit ganz unterschiedliche
erfahrungen gemacht teilweise gute
teilweise schlechte wir können aus der
vergangenheit was lernen damit wir jetzt
bestimmte fehler nicht wiederholen da
bin ich unbedingt dafür ganz wichtig
fehler nicht zu wiederholen übrigens
aber das was sie sagen setzt sozusagen
das messer so weit unten undershaft
freunde da bleibt ja gar nichts mehr
übrig sie sie töten sozusagen jede
unterhaltung über sinnvolle migration
und möglichkeiten von integration was
sie sagen geht sowieso nicht alles fremd
und die bleiben immer fremd
sondern sondern ich mache eben
unterschiede zunächst einwanderung
fangen wir mal an mit den usa es gab mal
in nordamerika indianer davon geht noch
ziemlich viel weil die zumindest haben
durch die haben durch die nach der
einwanderung gelitten wurden durch
andere verdrängen mich nicht
unterbrechen
außerdem können wir zeigen in europa es
gab immer einwanderung aber diese
einwanderung war im verhältnis zu den
für den nach der aufnehmenden staaten
und völkern minimal in brandenburg warnt
wanderten anfang des nach der
achtzehnten jahrhunderts damals hatte
brandenburg preußen anderthalb millionen
einwohner 20.000 sogenannten 1
meine vorfahren völlig recht die
allerdings um ein die allerdings nach
der deutlich der gebildeter und der
qualifizierter waren als die etwas als
sie etwas tun brandenburger den also ich
sehe noch etwas beibringen dass konnten
während heute haben wir in ganz grossem
umfang einwanderung die letztlich der
kultur fremd ist und letztlich auch uns
der wirtschaftlich nicht hilft
wirtschaftlich hilft nämlich nur
einwanderung wo die die einwanderer
qualifizierte sind als team in das land
eingewandert wird im einen fall nicht
kulturbegriff nicht sie sagen alles ist
die kultur die für den schlussendlich
currywurst und gartenzwerg es ist ein
wie fremd und wollen wir ganz klar eine
polemik ins studium ich trage ihren
kulturkreis kultur ist das wenn er ich
gehe nicht auf ihr niveau kultur ist
wenn wenn wenn zum beispiel eine einzige
gruppe gesetz hält erreichen will eine
eine gruppe der meinung ist dass bildung
nicht wichtig ist wenn eine gruppe ihrer
der frauen immer also zweiten rang hält
unterdrückt wenn eine wenn eine gruppe
wissens abgewandt ist und wenn eine
gruppe auch nach 50 jahren
in den schulen deutlich dass schlechter
abschneidet als die aufnehmende
bevölkerung dafür aber immer macht sich
das ist das ist kultur fremd und das
meine ich damit meine ich ja nicht den
einzelnen damit meine ich den
durchschnitt und dazu stehe ich auch
haben sie gelesen nein ich glaube nur
einfach die die voraussetzung von denen
sie ausgehen sind einfach falsch
natürlich sagt nochmals deutschland hat
aus der der rat für migration und da
sitzen entschuldigen sie im unterschied
zu ihnen wirklich experten drin hat
studien angestellt die zeigen dass
deutschland was die integration der
migranten der ersten wählen angeht gar
nicht so schlecht abgeschnitten hat viel
besser als sie immer den leuten
verkaufen wollen es gibt gegen in europa
da funktioniert das mit der integration
sehr sehr schlecht er die banlieues von
paris die wollen wir hier nicht haben
wir wollen ganz offensichtlich auch
nicht die stadtteile haben von brüssel
wo der salafist praktisch sich wohl
führt das haben wir hier bisher aber
auch nicht warum weil wir mit der
integration
obwohl wahnsinnig viele fehler gemacht
worden sind gar nicht so schlecht
gefahren sonst hätten wir hier nämlich
gar nicht politiker wie cem özdemir
wir hätten nicht leute wie tarik wazir
von interessanterweise bei den grünen
gibt es sie diesen teilweise deutscher
als die deutschen selbst für meinen
geschmack ist zum beispiel jemand wie
özdemir inzwischen von viel zu
schwäbisch da wäre ich froh wenn er noch
ein bisschen mehr sozusagen das
migrantische am leben hält dabei das
sind jetzt an reine geschmacksfrage
es ist contra faktisch was sie da sagen
lassen sie uns um die leute kümmern
lassen sie uns vor allem um die nächste
generation kümmern denn das sind die
kinder der migranten die sozusagen dann
die zukunft bringen aber sie geben diese
leute auf und dass das was ich so
verurteilt er
ein buch das ich dass sich gar nicht
aufgeben dass ich einfach von den von
den tatsachen aus wie sie so wie sie
sind es gibt eine traverse es gibt
anderen einen hatte tempels zu mir
aber sie sind leider mehr die ausnahme
als die regel und ich muss ja den
gesamten den gesamthaften durchschnitt
betrachten und vor den gesamthaften
berichtet gilt dass die einwanderung aus
aus aus der nahen mittel- ost- und
afrika wie sie über die letzten 50 jahre
stattfand uns wirtschaftlich geschadet
hat und in unserem land auf eine menge
probleme mit sich gebracht hat das kann
man ja ganz einfach zeigen ich möchte
gerade nicht die also zustände haben wie
in paris
ja da bin ich ja bei ihnen dabei und ich
bin da froh dass das dass das bei uns
besser ist und ich meine auch das sind
für die die bei uns sind alles tun muss
was vernünftigerweise möglich ist wir
müssen aber schauen dass sie zahlen sich
sich nicht sich nicht nach der ständig
weiter ungewollt erhöhen und wir müssen
auch sehen dass integration auch wenn
man das nicht gerne hört zunächst eine
der leistung ist derer die sich
integrieren noch keine gruppe wurde
deshalb nicht integriert weil sie
irgendwie von der gesellschaft abgelehnt
wurde sei es umgekehrt mit den schulen
engagiert immer an der gruppe selber die
kurve nach der wir die hat er zum
beispiel vietnamesen haben sich für uns
bestens integriert sind sind in den
schulen besser als die deutschen mit den
polen am berner in der der zweiten
generation überhaupt keine probleme mit
den mit den italienern relativ wenige es
ist sehr unterschiedlich je nach
ethnischer und kultureller entgegen und
jeder bürger gehen einen schritt weiter
ich würde sagen dass ich mir im letzten
jahr kamen etwa eine million leute ja
und was mich wirklich gewundert hat an
diesen ganzen debatten ist da stehen 80
leute zusammen und unterhalt sich von
einer dazu wer hat das sagen wer muss
sich dem anpassen
wer bedroht wenn an unsinn die ist die
öffentliche debatte war so als würden
wir überrannt praktisch unkontrollierte
einwanderung geflutet und so schon den
metaphern zeigen dass da die vernunft
sie sind auch ein grund vernünftiger
mensch warum reden
aus ihrem munde schon mal ein echtes
lobte auch wenn das dass er die sendung
gelohnt aber jetzt noch mal zu machen
die zahlen wenig ich weiß dass meine
zahlen hast den 80 millionen in
deutschland bestehen zu 30 aus der
menschen in meinem alter mit verlaub ich
bin noch also ziemlich rüstig aber ich
bin kein junger mann von 20 diejenigen
die kamen bestanden zu 70 bis 80 prozent
aus der jungen männern um den 20 bis 25
und in dieser altersgruppe haben
diejenigen die jetzt die jetzt
eingewandert sind bereits einen anteil
von etwa einem fünftel
hier wird also hier hier hier hier gibt
es also eine eine nach der umschichtung
von unten die auch mengenmäßig äußerst
bedeutend ist und das mit menschen die
in einem alter kommen wo sie einerseits
wenn sie da wenn sie der 20 sind noch
etwa 60 jahre leben werden was wir für
sie auch hoffen
zum anderen aber meist kein deutsch
können meist keine vernünftige
schulbildung haben und zu alt sind um in
unser arbeitsleben großenteils wirklich
integriert zu werden das heißt wir
schaffen hier bereite eine breite neue
unterschicht wo die verhältnisse das ist
nicht mein wunsch das ist meine bittere
prognose in 15 20 jahren wesentlich der
schlechter sein werden als bei denen bei
uns bisher angewendeten körper weshalb
pause
das haben wir jetzt mal fest dass sie
das ausmass der zuwanderung nach
deutschland und die art zu wahren und
vertraulich finden das hammerstatt
verstanden
ich glaube dass wir wollen jetzt ja auch
während dieser sendung nicht die
komplette einwanderungsdebatte noch
einmal wiederholt es hat ja die letzten
monate die debatte in deutschland
geprägt das hat die gesellschaft und vor
allem das parteiensystem verändert zum
beispiel ist auf die im hintergrund
dieser debatte die afd entstanden und
groß geworden hat am wochenende ihren
parteitag
abgehalten in stuttgart das großwerden
diese partei der afg ist das jetzt eine
gefahr für die demokratie oder im
prinzip eine ganz normale reaktion eines
gesunden parteiensystems dass da einfach
eine lehrstelle füllt das kommt drauf an
was sie unter demokratie verstehen wenn
sie sagen in russland in der türkei
teilweise auch im iran gibt es
demokratie weil er gewählt wird dann
würde ich sagen dann ist es keine gefahr
für die demokratie weil sie wollen sich
auch wählen lassen die wollen ja nicht
sozusagen per schießbefehl an der grenze
oder so pratsch mit gewalt die macht
übernehmen wenn sie demokratie anders
verstehen sein da gibt es bestimmte
werte der des gegenseitigen respekts
bestimmte institutionelle bedingungen
pressefreiheit öffentlich rechtlicher
rundfunk zum beispiel auch wichtiger
wichtiger aspekt so eine art liberale
kultur wenn sie sagen das gehört auch
zur demokratie dazu dass wir sozusagen
in deutschland vom westen gelernt haben
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg was wir
überhaupt allgemein den westen lernen
dann würde ich sagen ist es schon
erhebliche gefahr denn da hat sich
deutschland jetzt ein in andere
politische strömungen eine politische
strömung die in europa sehr mächtig
geworden ist der rechtspopulismus und
die wollen die in liberale demokratie
sowie das herr orban in ungarn vormacht
wie das jetzt auch die neue polnische
regierung vor macht nicht entmachtung
das verfassungsgericht ist zum beispiel
entmachtung des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks da wird immer noch gewählt
aber dass keine liberale demokratie mehr
und da will die afg auch insofern eine
gefahr
sarrazin die afg hat ja an vielen
punkten aufgenommen was sie in ihren
büchern angestoßen haben betrachten sie
das mit wohlwollen was die af deser
macht oder sagen sie
damit will ich nichts zu tun also also
jeder hat natürlich gerne beifall und
natürlich schaue ich auch oder hoffe ich
auch dass ich keinen beifall frost ja
aus der falschen ecke bekommen
einerseits muss ich sagen wenn ich eine
sache die für richtig halte mit zahlen
begründet für mich logisch begründet und
ist auch für wichtig halte dann
finde ich es auch nicht ungünstig wenn
mal solch eine position zum beispiel zum
beispiel etwas etwas mehr distanz
gegenüber einer falschen art von
einwanderung wenn solch eine position
öffentlich raum gewinnt wie die afg sich
als sich als partei entwickelt ob sie ob
sie in der lage ist also radikale
elemente auch also wirksam auszugrenzen
das ist eine andere frage im übrigen der
augstein mir ist auch nicht wohl wenn
ich sehe dass in ganz europa
letztlich also naturgruppe am rechten
rand der gesellschaft oder andere auf
der auf der rechten seite der
gesellschaft mittlerweile mittlerweile
über allen sich bei 30 etablieren
wenn dies aber in ganz unterschiedlichen
systemen logisch geht wie in frankreich
ungarn italien deutschland schweden
dänemark norwegen italien dann muss man
sagen vielleicht machen die etablierten
auch etwas falsch denn sonst könnte es
ja solch eine solch eine solch eine
einheitliche welle der distanz nicht
geben solange die etablierten aber seien
wir machen alles richtig wäre es nur
vielleicht falsch erklärt aber diese die
bösen und vor denen waren
das wird nicht so lange klären was
machen die etablierten falsch es ist
keine steilvorlage natürlich machen die
was falsch insofern ist das das problem
afd dass ich auch von anfang an habe ist
dass es ist die falsche antwort auf
wichtige fragen
das ist sozusagen mal jugendliche
erfahren schon mal ein fortschritt
ja ja wieso das so zu sagen viele leute
mit der globalisierung ein problem haben
weil sie sich entwurzelt fühlen dass
viele leute fassungslos zu gucken wie
die gesellschaft immer ungerechter
ungleicher wirtschaft in deutschland ist
inzwischen ein prozent der reichsten
leute besitzen 33 prozent der vermögen
und und wir haben jetzt irgendwie 15
jahre sozialdemokratie in der regierung
hinterfragt wo wären wir denn ohne die
noch gelandet
also das so zu sagen leute beobachten
wie fundamental sachen schief laufen und
gleichzeitig aber alle parteien sagen
wir müssen in die politische mitte wir
müssen in die mitte in der mitte werden
die wahlen gewonnen dadurch sich immer
stärker angleichen und offensichtlich
fragen unbeantwortet werden das sehe ich
auch dass beklage ich auch das problem
ist dass die afd
die antwort in ressentiments sucht und
selbst der dumme ausländer ist schuld
und wenn wir den syrer wieder nach hause
schicken und zäune aufbauen und die
nationen kümmern sich wiederum dann
werden die probleme gelöst und das ist
einfach unfug weil jeder mensch weiß
heute wir brauchen nicht weniger europa
sondern mehr das problem des euro ist
nicht sondern das problem ist die idee
war richtig aber man hat ihn falsch
gemacht weil die länder ihre kollegen
die idee ist richtig früher nur falsch
durchgeführt
die antwort ist wenn man es hat mich
richtig macht dann landet man im
rechtspopulismus genauer darüber beim
punkt also leben wir mal den euro ich
war mal ne für den euro das ist
allerdings 25 jahre her und ich war bis
bis vor zehn jahren für den euro bis ich
sah das so wie es wie es wie es
angefasst wurde eben nicht geht man kann
man kann eine gemeinsame währung haben
wenn man wenn man einen gemeinsamen
staat hat aber wenn man wenn man wenn
man keinen gemeinsamen staat hat schafft
gemeinsame währung mehr risiken als die
vorteile schafft das zum beispiel also
frankreich italien spanien griechenland
letztlich wäre der weniger stagnieren
und weit unter ihrem unter unter ihrem
wohlstands potenzial liegt ja auch daran
dass die du ihnen durch denen der euro
aufgefundene ordnungspolitik zu ihrer zu
ihrer der politischen kultur und ihrer
gesellschaftlichen kultur nicht passt
man hätte entweder weitergehen müssen
mit einem wirklich starken europäischen
zentralstaat aber jetzt sind wir in
einem ich meine man kann nicht wenn man
die springt mitten in der luft über über
einem abgrund stehen bleiben das geht
schief aus einem zeichentrickfilm da
kommt man nicht weiter
sonst aber nicht und insofern ist das
für mich ein typischer fall wo wir eine
idee nicht zu ende durchdacht haben und
dann noch die bremsen die wir gehabt
hatten weil wir achten dass die idee
nicht durchdachte am ende auch noch
weggenommen haben so dass aus meiner
sicht ist meine ich jetzt meine prognose
innerhalb der nächsten 20 jahre müssen
wir müssen wir entweder nach der vorn zu
einem zu einem der für einen
europäischen bundesstaat
wo ich aber keinen sehe außer vielleicht
und österreich die das wirklich wollen
oder es wird irgendwann zu ende sein mit
der gemeinsamen währung und das ist das
ist der typische fall wo politik die
dinge einfach da nicht zu ende gedacht
sondern als sie dann merkte plötzlich
geht jetzt wäre weniger in wunsch
einfach ausgewichen zu ende gedacht man
wusste ist als der 92 man wusste dass es
notwendig ist eine gemeinsame haftung
einzuführen gemeinsamen
wirtschaftspolitik ein einziger mann
wusste dass alles
man hat es nicht gemacht aus furcht
insofern ist ihre analyse der vollkommen
richtig die politiker hatten angst die
richtigen schritte zu machen das sehe
ich auch so
das was wir jetzt erleben ist sozusagen
sind die sind die das sind die risse das
sind die erschütterungen die tarif von
dieser fuchs herkommen die antwort kann
man nicht noch mehr furcht sein dass
dort das was wir jetzt daraus lernen wir
die antwort muss doch sein wenn angst
und sind diese klemme gebracht hat dann
und verzagtheit dann müssen wir jetzt
heraus dass der vertrag mit den schritt
nach vorne machen aber das wird noch
schlimmer die engländer ich meinen ganz
gut wenn denn die engländer rausgehen
aus der eu alle das sagen alle und ich
bin jetzt gar nicht so ein
wirtschaftsliberaler aber alle leute die
von geld was verstehen von wirtschaft
sagen sie schießen sich in den eigenen
fuß rein zahlenmäßig und trotz ihre
zahlen trotzdem ist aber ein großer teil
der engländer dafür aus den aus der eu
auszutreten vollkommen unsinnig weil
sozusagen es eben nicht um zahlen geht
sondern um andere die haben jetzt ist
der punkt ich bin erstmal gegen den
britischen austritt
zum anderen die briten doch dafür
stimmen haben wir etwas falsch gemacht
zum dritten ist aber folgen der punkt
entscheidend
wir entscheiden nicht alleine in europa
mit deutschen ist er vielleicht auch gut
so
und deshalb müssen wir einfach sehen ist
es möglich zusammen mit frankreich und
polen das sind die beiden zentralen
mächte letztlich für uns zu einem zu
einem dafür einem europäischen
bundesstaat zu kommen
oder ist das nicht möglich meine meine
prognose ist ist gewünscht war
es wird in den nächsten 50 jahren
unmöglich sein wenn es aber in den
nächsten 50 jahren unmöglich ist
dann haben wir es dann haben wir es mit
der damit der gemeinsamen währung falsch
gemacht das ist das problem
jetzt will ich gerne an der stelle die
debatte über den euro beenden und wieder
etwas zurück kehren zudem wie sich
unsere gesellschaft verändert hat
aufkommender afd
zentraler satz des parteiprogramms an
diesem wochenende der islam gehört nicht
zu deutschland
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sie
diesem satz zustimmen die frage ist nur
ist das eine meinungsäußerung die im
spektrum der meinungsäußerungen möglich
ist oder ist das ihrer ansicht nach
schon jenseits dessen was unsere
verfassung zulässt gottes wäre natürlich
ist verfassungsmäßig kann das natürlich
jeder sagen wer lust hat eine politische
partei das macht hat das eine andere
qualität als wenn sie und ich das abends
am stammtisch praktisch so der islam
wird nicht zu deutschland
wenn die politische partei damit ins
rennen geht spaltet sie das land wir
haben bereits einen sehr großen teil von
muslimischen mitbürgern
fragen sie mal wie die sich fühlen wenn
sie das hören die denken was sollen das
wir ich bin hier geboren ich komme
irgendwie aus köln
meine mama eltern sind hier vielleicht
teilweise geboren meine großeltern
eingewandert ich arbeite hier jetzt sagt
man mit der islam gehört nicht zu
deutschland was für ein unsinn
ich will übrigens auch gar nicht dass
sich unser land religiös konfessionell
definiert da möchte ich bitte auch
gefragt werden
hallo freunde mal ganz entspannt ich bin
nicht mal getauft also nur der
protestantismus deutschland oder der
katholizismus was soll denn das nein wir
haben ein grundgesetz wir haben eine
leitkultur
das ist mir ganz wichtig natürlich
brauchen wir eine leitkultur und ehrlich
gesagt haben wir auch längst ein und die
funktioniert relativ gut finde ich denn
viele sachen funktion so viel geld damit
verdienen kann dass das land immer
schlecht zu machen wie sie das machen
sie haben echtes der nische sie sagen
das alles total schlecht los ich bin in
der ganzen erkenne ich mit ihnen reden
ganz komischen rolle
plötzlich muss ich sagen so viele dinge
funktionieren hier viel viel besser als
east darstellte ungeahnte folge diese
wer sarrazin die fdp übt kritik am islam
sie üben kritik am islam was
unterscheidet ihre kritik am islam von
der dfg erstmal noch vielleicht zudem
schlecht machen ich bin von nach von
haus aus der skeptiker und die länder
welche von der skeptikern regiert werden
sind die reichen länder die länder die
von optimise montiert werden sind die
armen länder das ist der unterschied
zwischen zwischen zwischen griechenland
und deutschland sie nur was wir
deutschen eine eine fähigkeit haben
unheil vorher zu ahnen sind wir auch
waren wir oft auch besser als andere in
der lage manche dinge zu steuern also
insofern machen sie machen sie mir meine
beine nach der skepsis nicht kaputt im
übrigen bin ich in meinen büchern was
die fakten angeht immer absolut sachlich
und differenzieren was ist der
unterschied oder oder interessiert an
gemeinsam als der als als also
bundespräsident wulff sagte der islam
gehört zu deutschland dachte ich was für
ein quatsch
weil also regionen sind nicht von dieser
welt religion gehen und die frage gibt
es eine nach der jungfrauengeburt oder
nicht passen drei engel auf eine auf
eine nahrung spitze oder nicht wenn der
liebe gott da als wo sitzt er im
weltraum haben wir eine unsterbliche
seele die stars dinge die sind nicht von
dieser welt können wir auch gar nicht
beurteilen die müssen auch im privaten
bleiben weil sonst gibt es mord und
totschlag deshalb gehört keine religion
zu deutschland sondern bei uns können
alle alle dann nach ihrer fasson selig
werden
das ist der richtige standort
lassen sie doch mal ich wollte ihnen
doch ein bisschen entgegen kommunalen zu
nett zu mir sind aber jedenfalls und
dessen und und ebenso ein und sehen wie
die aussage der islam gehört zu
deutschland diese aussage der islam
gehöre nicht zu deutschland weil er eher
er stellt aus dem aus den segeln aus dem
der dance theatre die dinge auf den kopf
richtig ist es gehören muslime zu
deutschland und nun ist der nächste
punkt natürlich können können muslime
ihren ihren glauben aus wir müssen aber
auch in umfragen ernst nehmen wonach in
der europa der zwei drittel aller
muslime letztlich sagen dass das im
zweifel das gesetz der religion vor dem
vor dem weltlichen gesetz vorrang haben
soll und haben muss und danach also 44
prozent aller muslime in europa
fundamentalistischen ansichten zu meiden
und die smoothies zusammennehmen damit
dass sich einig samarra die kahler
politische islamismus der nicht den
ganzen islam darstellt aber doch ein
teil von e mails unter unserer jugend
mehr und mehr ausbreitet und das ist
äußerst gefährdet also liegt die zahlen
kann können wir jetzt hier ein
jugendlicher übergriffen herausstellt
der islam als politische ideologie der
hat ja nun in der tat probleme mit der
gleichstellung der frauen mit der
toleranz mit den rechten ich habe den
eindruck dass das so ist glauben sie das
ist nicht der fall ist also ich bin
jetzt kann religionswissenschaftler wenn
sie das denn dann
dann will dann klären sie mich auf ich
glaube dass der islam ist eine religion
wie für 1,6 milliarden 1,2 milliarden
menschen auf der welt als frau von ex
von marokko bis indonesien
es gibt den islam nicht wissen sie
eigentlich viel christlichen ansatz
englisches land in dem sexuellen gleiche
rechte haben die frauenrechte
aber ich bin doch ihr kaste dürfen mich
dann zerbricht
wissen sie eigentlich wie viele
christliche kirchen es geht ich glaube
es gibt es gibt buchstäblich zigtausende
christliche kirche und es werden immer
mehr weil diese ganzen pfingst und
advents gemeinden und so wie jeder der
keine lust hat der gründe dann seine
eigene kirche
wenn sie jetzt sagen das christentum
dieser begriff ist vollkommen unsinnig
wir haben uns aber daran gewöhnt mit
diesem wort zu arbeiten das schlicht
keinen sinn macht wenn sie jetzt sagen
wir haben probleme mit dem islam dann
meinen sie doch ganz was anderes sie
malen sie haben probleme mit einer
bestimmten glaubensrichtung des islam
die hauptsächlich in saudi arabien der
wahabismus der dort sozusagen gepflegt
wird und finanziert wird mit dem öl
dollar die wir dort hinschicken usw
aber dann sind sie gleich im politischen
verwicklungen drin wir haben kein
problem mit den islam sehen sie übrigens
auch an der an den türkischen migranten
die soweit ich weiß bisher jedenfalls
für irgendwelche form von
fundamentalismus überhaupt nicht
anfällig sind
das sind alles muslime machen die das
aber sehr still bei sich zuhause auswahl
ehrlich gesagt aufwendig werden die
damit nicht also ich glaube dass jetzt
sagen ich glaube dass ihre prämisse
nicht stimmt deshalb kann ich ihre frage
auf so nicht beantworten wir haben kein
problem mit dem islam sondern mit
bestimmten glaubensrichtung im islam das
ist wichtig also wir haben ich bin ich
bin oft ein islamwissenschaftler aber
ich nach der lese leute ich hab jetzt
gelesen von nach der ahmed mansur der
genau zeigt was unter unter unserer
muslimischen jugend im augenblick los
ist es gibt andere namen der nächste
könig haben mit updates und so weiter da
haben sie einen anderen rheine eine
ganze reihe von namen die letztlich auf
die gefahren hinweisen und ich sehe
diese gefahren auch übrigens das ist der
unterschied denken sie an die der
titanic das sagte der kapitän
es gibt keine gefahr eines eisbergs ich
sehe keinen wir fahren mal vollgas
geradeaus so ist das wenn man wenn man
gefahren vernachlässigt wie das geendet
hat hat man der gewusst ich persönlich
sehe in einer in einer wachsenden
ausbreitung einer
also nach der fundamentalen islamismus
in ganz europa ein großes problem es ist
ja auch ein nach der demografisches
problem wenn wir sehen dass mittlerweile
das mittlerweile nach der muslimische
kinder und jugendliche in frankreich 25
prozent anteil haben an der altersgruppe
und zu 50% radikalisiert sind lassen
lass uns reden über über polizeiarbeit
über prävention über empfehlung über
bildung in den schulen über bildung in
den betrieben übrigens noch mal
deutschland gar nicht so schlecht das
duale ausbildungssystem ist sehr sehr
gut um solche leute rein zu nehmen ganz
verblüffend jetzt die ganzen
handwerksverbände die sagen dass die
syrischen flüchtlinge schneller arbeiten
wir können die wunderbar gebrauchen denn
wir haben lehrstellenmangel und so
weiter es gibt zu all diesen problemen
noch mal ich sage nicht dass die
probleme die sie beschreiben dass die
nicht gibt ich bin ja ich sag nicht wie
ich hat die rosarote multikulti brille
auf wir fassen uns alle an den händen
singen kommen bei jahren alles ist toll
dass meine ich überhaupt nicht im
gegenteil ich sage es gibt ganz viele
herausforderungen probleme und mit
praktischer politik können wir die auch
alle lösen so wie wir das in der
vergangenheit gemacht haben was sie
machen ist weltuntergangs gerede damit
verdienen sie viel geld und was die afg
macht ist hetze und rassismus und damit
kriegen die viele wählerstimmen ich
finde beides wirklich schlimm für unser
land
redet sondern ich beschreibe der
bestimmte trends und beschreibe was man
was man tun muss damit diese sich in
dieser form nicht fortsetzen und ich
muss einfach zur kenntnis nehmen dass
bei all dem was unser was unser
ausbildungssystem tut und kann mir
feststellen müssen dass unsere nach der
türkischen und nach der beständigen
mitbürger in den vergangenen 50 jahren
einfach weit aus der weniger erfolg
hatten auch in der bildung auch am
arbeitsmarkt als andere
einwanderungsgruppen und ich bin auch
der meinung wenn es gibt keine andere
ursache
das hat zu tun mit ihrer mit ihrer nach
der herkunftskultur und auch
wahrscheinlich mit ihrer der herkunft
religion ich bin der meinung dass man
das für diese gruppen lösen muss glaube
allerdings auch dass das diese gruppen
selber tun müssen das kann kein anderer
da für sie tun
ich meine aber auch dass man
einwanderung aus aus aus den derselben
kulturkreisen bei uns für die zukunft
damit wir das wir welt gehen können
strikt beschränken muss also was sie
immer teufeln ist wenn christen zu
muslimen sagen ihr brachten papst so das
ist das aber gar nicht gesagt aber das
ist ja auch sagen der nächste satz dann
das müssen die selber lösen wir gucken
von außen die ansagen ihr entspricht gar
nicht so richtig unseren vorstellungen
wie man so zu sein hat als moderne
religion heutzutage dann müsst ihr euch
aber echt noch nicht ran halten und
modernisiert und dieser art von kultur
dünkel sind da kriege ich irgendwie so
oder rappelt sich mir alles was uns
trennt sich um die religion herbstein
weil die mich mit verlaub nicht
interessiert sondern es geht nicht darum
wie sich menschen im realen leben
verhalten wie die männer ihre frauen
behandeln wann die täter waren die
frauen heiraten weshalb sie die nach der
schule nicht zu ende machen dürfen
weshalb sie weshalb sie nicht der
teilnehmen dürfen am der
schwimmunterricht hunderte dinge deshalb
so wenige von ihnen im bildungssystem
dringend als mein vater will eingehen
sie nicht doch gehen sie doch enttäuscht
wenn das bundesamt für
migrationsforschung erzeugen das sind
die leute die sich wirklich damit
beschäftigen die haben vielleicht doch
ein bisschen mehr
in der sache schulen melden haben nicht
haben nachgehakt schon wieder lügen
presse man aber jetzt sein was nicht
abweichen das ist so dass es hier
einfach quatsch es gibt schon gar kein
schwimmunterricht mehr können so ist es
wir geben immer ist der spaß in der wir
leben in berlin am meisten geld der
schüler aus dass das ist der punkt
im übrigen ist es so und das ist das
haftung wenn sie sich wenn sie sich
unsere unsere also türken und nach der
aber anschauen wird sie gäste jetzt da
seit 50 jahren bei uns leben großenteils
mittlerweile deutschen staatsbürger so
sind sie einfach in der arbeitsmarkt
beteiligung und in der
bildungsbeteiligung ganz weit hinten und
beim sozialhilfebezug bei der
arbeitslosigkeit bei der
erwerbslosigkeit ganz weit vorn und
damit kosten sie als der gruppe weitaus
mehr als sie uns wirtschaftlich bringen
und diese berechnen das halte ich für
das anders das ist das ist angewandte
soziologie was ich hier tue das kann man
berechnen und das wird sich bei denen
die da jetzt kommen noch weiter
verstärken
was ja auch so viel miete stand jetzt
bei herrn augstein und auch auf
verbreitet in der gesellschaft stößt ist
diese linearen zusammenhänge die sie
daher stellen zwischen zwischen zwischen
dem dem glauben einer bevölkerungsgruppe
und dem dem integrationserfolg den
bildungserfolg einer einer
bevölkerungsgruppe also der vorwurf
steht im raum dass dem individuellen
menschen überhaupt keine
entwicklungsperspektive zu seligen das
mal wenn ich wenn ich etwas über über
über eine bestimmte gruppe sich über
nichts
über keinen einzelnen etwas das gilt
aber nicht für einzelne man für die
einzelne frau ich sehe einfach die nach
der sozioökonomischen daten für diese
gruppen ich sehe dass die in ganz europa
einheitlich sind in schweden england
frankreich teilweise aber auch noch
schlimmer als bei uns und dann frage ich
was vereint diese gruppen und diese
gruppen vereint ihre der herkunft aus
dem aus dem nahen und mittleren osten
und aus und aus afrika und es vereint
sie ihr großenteils muslimischer glaube
und ich sehe dass die ostasiaten zb ganz
anders sind und wie das sehe ich und das
sind fakten die kann man belegen und die
sind vielfach belegt und dann aber dann
frage ich was sind die ursachen und wege
zu sagen es hat andere ursachen wenn wir
doch operiert
ich sehe als kulturelle herz oder wo es
ganz ganz viele störche gibt gibt es
auch ganz ganz viele babys das heißt
aber nicht dass die störche die beatles
ihren mann ist ein alter sozusagen das
statistische fehlschlüsse was sie da
machen und ich glaube und dahinter
vermute ich sozusagen weil sie den
arbeitsmarktforscher koopmann und das
ist genau das jetzt wieder untersucht
sie tun so als handelten sie mit fakten
in watt handeln sie mit ideologien und
das etwas was sich ganz besonders krass
finde wenn leute das machen sie tun so
sie sagen das ist alles wissenschaftlich
das sind zahlen das ganz nüchtern
ich habe damit gar nichts zu tun ich
präsentiere euch das nur in wahrheit
sind es ideologien die sie verbreiten
und deshalb ist auch kein wunder dass
leute wie von der afg sie begierig
herangezogen haben ich meine sie sind
ein bedeutender mann weil sie ab 2011
die waren der erste im dorf 2010 dann
entschuldigen sie 2010 sie waren der
erste der diesen diskurs angefangen hat
und in salonfähig gemacht hat und ganz
viele haben danach gesagt guck mal das
geht ja man kann das ja alles sagen und
es funktioniert und sie haben ich weiß
gar nicht ob ihnen das bewusst war
damals oder bis ihn jetzt bewusst ist so
wie ich sehr schätze ist das auch gar
nicht der punkt darum geht es gar nicht
glaube es war wissen weshalb das gemacht
hat
sie haben eine tür geöffnet durch die
nachher ganz viele gegangen sind das
waren erst motiviert durch die sie
gegangen sind
die anderen haben sie doch breiter
aufgemacht und inzwischen stimmt die
ganze afd durch und wird eine
volkspartei werden das ist wirklich an
sie haben eine schlimme entwicklung
ausgelöst hatte hat sie also zunächst
einmal ich habe ich habe keine ideologie
sondern ich mache es der wie jeder der
sich der dichter mit der wirklichkeit
beschafft faz erstmal daten und fakten
aufzunehmen über die wirklichkeit und
dann sieht er und dann sieht der
auffälligkeiten und dann sucht er nach
denkbaren erklärungen für diese
unterschiede und für mich können diese
unterschiede
juli nimmt nach der kulturellen in der
religiösen hintergrund und in der
ethnischen herkunft oder endet in der
nach der kombination von allem beiden im
übrigen im übrigen nach der meine bücher
der schienen in deutschland sie sie
erschien nicht in schweden nicht in
norwegen nicht in dänemark nicht in
holland
da wurde in frankreich in der
übersetzung das ist richtig aber auch
nicht mit dieser auflage nicht in
italien
wir haben doch vorhin eine eine eine
nach der bewegung beschrieben die über
ganz europa geht so können jetzt sagen
mein buch ist davon auch ein ausdruck
möglicherweise ist es das teilweise dass
ich mich überhaupt mit solchen fragen
gefasst habe aber wenn sie sagen
sarrazin hat das verursacht machen sie
mich einerseits stolz weil ich so
mächtig bin andererseits auch jetzt alle
geistig er fassungslos denn das einfach
unsinn
ich würde am ende dieser sendung gerne
noch mal den versuch unternehmen
ob es eine ebene gemeinsam
gesprächsfähigkeit von ihnen beiden sind
also dass sie in der sache nicht
zueinander kommen das hatte ich auch vor
dieser sendung nicht erwartet und nicht
gehofft wie findet trotzdem
interessieren ob sie beide an einen weg
sehen wie
die debatte über die flüchtlingskrise
über den islam in deutschland geführt
werden könnte das am ende ein sinnvolles
ergebnis steht und nicht einfach in zwei
teile der gesellschaft die sich
überhaupt nicht verstehen von sima also
erst einmal um das auch zu sagen das ist
auch schon deutlich geworden
ich bin absolut dagegen nach der
religion als solche in ein eck zu
stellen
das habe ich wohl auch deutlich gemacht
so zum anderen bin ich der meinung dass
man alles was irgendwie machbar und
vernünftig ist um menschen dazu helfen
sich zu integrieren
die bei uns leben das war das noch tun
muss dass sich was das resultat angeht
ich hab das skeptischer bin auf manche
andere ist eine andere sache das ändert
aber nicht ergeben dass ich meine dass
man da was tun muss
wie kann eine sinnvolle debatte
exemplarisch zwischen ihnen beiden
und generell in der gesellschaft
aussehen damit fruchtbar wird ich glaube
das leben ohne gefühl nicht funktioniert
sie betreiben ideologie komplett ohne
jede empathie sie führen sich überhaupt
nicht einen die leute über die sie
sprechen sie interessieren sich nicht
für die menschen weder für die migranten
die damals bekommen sind noch für der
nachkommen heute noch für die
flüchtlinge das ist ihnen sozusagen auf
der empathische ebene
es wird in ihren büchern und in ihren
interviews nicht deutlich sagen wir mal
so insofern glaube ich dass das die
reduktion auf zahlen abgesehen davon
dass sich viele von denen ich teile wird
so nicht funktionieren ich glaube was
wir brauchen ist gute praktische politik
und das interessante ist doch dass wenn
sie reden mit den leuten die das machen
die bürgermeister die landräte die vor
ort sich kümmern
da ist die gesamte stimmung viel weniger
alarmistisch als sie schreiben und als
die afg ist oben abschöpft und als sie
es bei twitter und facebook sind die
leute die es machen
die wollen praktische hilfe die wollen
ernst genommen werden und dann können
sich diese probleme auch lösen lassen
aber wenn man das schlecht redet und
sagt irgendwie das in unsere feinde die
könnte hier nie integrieren es wird
alles noch schlimmer
dann können sachen auch kippen und dann
kann es wirklich dramatisch schiefgehen
in dem deutschland möchte ich dann
allerdings nicht mehr
ob das müssen wir jetzt einfach so
stehen lassen ist nicht ganz
überraschend dass wir da keinen konsens
herstellen konnte ich darf mich bei
ihnen bedanken für diese lebendige
debatte liebe zuschauer live zuschauer
im norden zur selben zeit die phoenix
runde des themas salafisten schläfer
terroristen wie gefährdet ist
deutschland ich wünsche ihnen weiter
informative unterhaltung mit unserem
programm